Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous fait un deuxième épisode sur le sens caché de certains logos,
et l'explication de petits secrets de certaines marques.
La dernière fois, j'en avait fait 10, aujourd'hui j'en ferai 7.
Parce qu'il n'y a pas de règles !
[musique]
Pour le premier on va s'intéresser à Snapchat que vous connaissez très bien.
On ne va pas se mentir, moi, j'ai découvert l'appli un peu tardivement...
"Snapchat" au départ devait s'appeler "Picaboo", et "Picaboo" c'est le nom du fantôme qui a sur le logo.
Sauf qu'ils ont eu un problème de taille avec ça, puisque "Picaboo" c'était déjà un nom pris et déposé par une société d'albums photos.
Donc ils n'ont pas pu le réutiliser professionnellement.
A la dernière minute, ils ont changé. Pour "Sanpchat" qui est un mixte entre "Snapshot" qui est un instantané, et "chat" la discussion.
C'est donc devenu Snapchat, mais le fantôme le Picaboo est resté sur le logo, puisque derrière la notion de fantôme se cache des fois le côté des photos qui disparaissent.
En numéro 2, on va parler du logo d'Apple.
Oui, vous me l'avez beaucoup demandé dans les commentaires.
Il a été créé en 1975 par Ron Wein qui est un des cofondateurs d'ailleurs.
Dès le départ c'était une pomme.
En fait la pomme faisait référence à Newton et à la gravité puisqu'il y a une légende urbaine qui raconte que Newton s'est prit une pomme sur la tête
quand il était assis sous un pommier, et c'est comme ça qu'il a pensé au système de la gravité.
Et c'est en 1977 que Steeve Jobs fait changer la pomme pour qu'elle soit croquée en arc-en-ciel.
Et alors là, il y a des théories et pleins d'hypothèses sur pourquoi la pomme était croquée, pourquoi il y a un arc-en-ciel à l'intérieur.
Beaucoup pense que c'est une référence à Alan Turing.
Alan Turing c'est un génie qui a décripté le code enigma des nazis durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
Mais qui était homosexuel.
Et à l'époque être homosexuel, là où il habitait, c'était complètement illégal.
Malgré son exploi il devait aller en prison.
Et pour échapper à la prison il a croqué une pomme empoisonné, pleine de cyanure.
Une sorte de référence à Blanche Neige.
Il y a une deuxième qui dit simplement que la pomme croquée c'est le symbole de la connaissance.
Là, ce serait une référence biblioque à Adan et Eve.
Impossible de savoir ce qui est vrai ou ce qui n'est pas vrai,
en tout cas officiellement ils ont expliqué que la pomme croquée, c'était simplement pour ne pas qu'on confondent la pomme avec une cerise.
Et les couleurs de la pomme, n'avait aucune référence à l'époque avec ce qui deviendra plus tard le drapeau gay,
Et par extension au lgbt aujourd'hui.
Mais simplement pour mettre en avant le fait que c'étaient des moniteurs de couleurs.
En 3, je vais vous parler de quelques facts interessants sur Tinder. Ouais Tinder !
Alors "tinder" c'est un mot qu'on utilise pour toutes les petites choses à computions rapides.
Ce dont on peut se servir pour faire un allume feu par exemple.
Donc une feuille de papier, du petit bois, des allumettes, des journaux, un allume feu... Ce genre de choses.
Tout ça, ça fait parti d'une famille qu'on pourrait appeler le "tinder".
C'est du tinder, c'est de l'allume feu...
Donc l'applicaiton fait référence à ça, et c'est pour ça que vous avez une flamme sur le "i" de "Tinder".
Et forcément le tinder c'est quelque chose qui s'enflamme très vite et qui est vite réduit à l'état de cendres.
Donc l'application s'affiche clairement comme quelque chose qui s'enflamme vite, mais qui ne dure pas forcément dans le temps.
Tant qu'on est dans les marques américaines, je vous parle de Starbuck.
C'est Thierry Heclore qui a créé le logo en 1971 et qui a aussi d'ailleurs trouvé le nom de la marque.
Le nom de la marque. [essaie d'articuler]
Il faut que j'articule des fois...
Il s'est simplement inspiré d'une sirène scandinave avec les cheveux.
Bon, pourquoi pas ! C'était considéré comme une déesse.
Et là, vous vous dites: "Pourquoi une sirène ?"
Hein ?! Ben, je vais vous dire pourquoi ! [imitation N.Sarkozy]
Parce qu'il voulait lier le café au côté séduction.
Et là, vous ne voyez peut-être pas le rapport entre la séduction et le café,
mais c'est quelque chose qui est utilisé depuis tout le temps, et encore aujourd'hui.
C'est pas pour rien qu'encore à l'heure actuelle vous avez une pub pour le café qui fini par:
"What else ?"
En 1987, la marque est rachetée par une marque de café, d'expresso italien.
Avec comme nouveau logo, une tête de romain à la place,
pour ensuite fusionner le vert du logo avec la sirène, mais ils avaient juste un problème, c'était le problème de la poitrine.
On voyait la poitrine de la sirène, donc ils ont remonté un petit peu le logo.
Et pour la petite histoire en plus, "Starbuck" ça vient du nom d'un officier qu'on trouve dans le roman de Moby Dick.
On arrive déjà au cinquième qui me plaît particulièrement.
C'est le logo de "Northwest Airlines".
Ce logo paraît très simple, ça semble rien, et pourtant il est extrêmement ingénieux.
Parce que dedans en négatif on arrive à retrouver le "N" et le "W", de Nord West.
Maintenant que je vous le dis vous devriez voir très clairement le N et le W si on raccorde tout.
Et là où c'est très malin, c'est que la petite flèche qui est détachée, ça peut nous faire penser simplement à une boussole.
Et si on regarde par rapport au cercle elle est placée où ?
Bam !
Au Nord-Ouest !
En sixième on va parler d'un fast-food.
Non, pas de Macdo, pas de Quick non plus, on va parler de KFC.
KFC a été créé en 1952, ça s'appelait le "Kentucky Fried Chicken", et en 1991 ils veulent quelque chose de plus impactant,
donc ils prennent la première lettre de chaque mot pour faire: KFC.
Et il y a une personne sur le logo, vous ne vous êtes pas forcément demandé qui c'est...
C'est un colonel !
C'est surtout le fondateur de la chaîne, qui s'appelle Harland Sanders.
Et on va finir avec le septième qui sera un petit peu plus long, parce que je vais vous en donner plusieurs en vrai dans le septième, ça fera des bonus.
Ce sont ces logos un petit peu malins et lisibles dans tous les sens.
Alors il y a le logo de "Sun", qui est apparemment un petit peu connu.
Je ne sais pas si vous le connaissiez.
A chaque fois qu'on tourne à 90 degrès, on peut toujours lire "Sun" à chaque fois.
Donc il est lisible dans tous les sens.
Il y a le logo de Osh...
Oyshow...?
Oisho ?
Osho ?
En fait c'est une marque de lingerie et comme je ne mets pas beaucoup de lingerie je ne connais pas la prononciation de cette marque là.
Les filles vous pouvez nous dire en phonétique dans les commentaires comment ça se prononce.
Grâce au Y et au H, la manière dont ils l'ont dessiné, si on retourne le logo de 180 degrés, on peut encore lire le nom de la marque.
Et la dernière fois je vous ai parlé du TGV, mais il y a quelque chose qui va remplacer le TGV qui s'appelle le "inoui".
Et encore une fois, la SNCF a fait un logo qui se retourne, parce que si on retournée "inoui", on lit...?
Je te le donne Emile, "inoui".
Le secret il est vraiment dans le nom du train, dans la marque du train,
dans "inoui", parce que il se lit en 6 dimensions différentes.
Le O de "inoui", le O qu'il y a au milieu représente une bulle de confort en fait.
C'est vraiment le message qu'ils veulent mettre en avant; dans notre train vous êtes dans une bulle.
Le "Oui" de "inoui" c'est leur intention de répondre positivement à casiment toutes les demandes.
Le "Nou" de "inoui", c'est le message clair que veut faire passer la SNCF en ce moment,
c'est-à-dire rapprocher les équipes et les utilisateurs.
Donc en clair, ça veut dire "rapprochons nous !".
"Ino" de "inoui", c'est le "ino" de "innovation".
Parce que clairement ces trains là ils vont être connectés en Wifi, il va y avoir des applications...
Ils veulent s'inscrire dans le digital avec ça.
"In" de "inoui", ça vous le savez. "In" ça veut dire "dedans".
C'est un signe de mordernité.
Et enfin la globalité, "inoui" c'est la promesse qu'ils essayent de nous faire dans le message marketing.
De dire le service va être inoui.
Je ne sias pas ce que ça va donner ce train, par contre je trouve qu'au niveau du travail de recherche préalable, là ils ont cartonné !
Maintenant on va prendre un petit rendez-vous ensemble, la prochaine vidéo elle sera ce dimanche à 11H donc soyez là.
Je dédicacerai le livre le 24 juin à La Rochelle et le 28 juin à côté de Caen.
Vous avez les infos sur mon site Internet dans la section "livres" ou dans la vidéo dont je vous mets le liens dans la description.
Et évidemment le livre est toujours dans toutes les librairies: Fnac, Amazon, etc.
Et maintenant je nous vous pas vous challenger, mais la dernière fois que j'ai fait une vidéo sur ce sujet, on a été premier des tendances.
Donc je compte sur vos pouces, vos partages, vos commentaires, parce que vous êtes au top les mecs !
Rendez-vous dimanche à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique]